five years ago two US special agents on
a covert mission were ambushed by hitmen
from Mexico's deadliest drug cartel the
sole survivor of that attack was Victor
Avila and he's never spoken about what
he witnessed that day he tells us how
his partner was murdered how their own
government betrayed them both and of a
political cover-up that persists to this
day at the very highest level here in
Washington DC
[Music]
on the morning of the 15th of February
2011 two federal agents are dispatched
from the US Embassy in Mexico City on a
covert mission
they have been ordered to pick up
surveillance equipment for an operation
that is part of the never ending war and
goes but the senior agent the serious
concerns about the group that has been
chosen that was vocally upset because
there's been a lot of security incidents
and there's a lot of security issues
surrounding that highway highway 57 the
two men have been ordered to travel
along one of the most dangerous roads in
Mexico it runs through the heart of
territory controlled by one of the
country's most powerful drug cartels
they are Los Zetas an organization
notorious for their brutality
look at the u.s. embassy Victor's
concern is shared by another member of
diplomatic staff his wife I know that he
contacted people in Monterrey who agreed
with Victor that it was very dangerous I
felt like I was in the twilight zone
like how can this be possible I can't
believe they're sending you there
everyone knew I didn't want to go and I
was ordered at that point as a
government employee you you follow
orders or you're dismissed
Victor's companion on the journey is
famous a pattern recently transferred to
Mexico from the US on a temporary
posting
even though Victor has known him for
less than 24 hours he is quickly formed
an impression of his new partner there's
a brave man out there he was one of them
he wanted to go he wanted to go there
and be there in the front line to serve
his country the pair of traveling in a
bulletproof suburban SUV supplied by
their agency Immigration and Customs
Enforcement known as ice the agents make
their collection and set off back to
Mexico City with Jaime Zapata now
driving I was on the phone I called my
supervisor I informed him that we had
just picked up the equipment and we were
on our way back and our estimated time
of arrival and entering the city will be
sometime at rush hour
but the agents are not alone they are
being tracked by two carloads of
devastates economies cartel hit men who
are looking to find out their vehicle
Jaime noticed that there was a London
the barrel of a long gun sticking out
from the back of the seat and then I
picked over and looked at I said I see
that I said and notice that the that
suburban was occupied for by multiple
individuals they get very very close
very close
I tell him you're not gonna pull over
not gonna floor go go go go go
eventually what they do is make end up
like a rolling road block at this point
I have my hands up closest to the
windshield as I can
Jaime has them on top on top of the
steering wheel like this and I yell at
them we are Americans we are US Embassy
employees this is a diplomatic vehicle
we are diplomats they didn't care they
all had evil in their faces and in their
eyes two shooters approached me at my
window and before I know it they
introduced an ak-47 and a handgun right
here and I immediately put my head back
and I went up two against the post of
the suburban and with my hand I hit the
window to raise it
[Music]
there's nowhere to run
we're trapped in the front two seats I
could see I may get hit with the handgun
and then I see him get hit with the
ak-47 in his leg I went back to the
button and eventually they pulled the
barrels out and the window in it and
then they sprayed it with bullets
I mean it's yelling at me I'm shot
I'm hit I said go go go go go go go go
and he he wouldn't go so I with my left
hand grab the gear shift and slam it
down and push I'm his right leg onto the
gas pedal the vehicle just rolls into
the median with no power
I missed telling me that he's gonna die
I tell Matt he's not that I'm calling
for help but he was bleeding profusely I
could not do anything to control his leg
the woman his leg and I see a SUV drive
out and I think that they're leaving but
it stops and does a u-turn
and two individuals come out and they
look at me and I look at them and they
both shoot it takes me a couple of
seconds to realize that the bullets that
they're not coming in that the glass is
stopping the realms and partial the the
partial vision that I had was when they
stopped shooting they get in and they go
I realized that I had been shot in my
chest here and in my leg and so my left
leg looked like a watermelon and it was
bleeding profusely
I call the US Embassy and when they
answer it routes my call to the regional
Security office and the regional
Security office the rest receptionist
answers our is oh and I tell her my name
is Special Agent Victor Avila I work for
ice Immigration and Customs Enforcement
we have been shot there's an agent down
we need help we need help now I walk
towards the front desk and she's on the
phone and she's screaming agent Avila
has been shot agent Avila has been shot
I lost it I can't remember what I did
but I know that I was escorted I started
yelling I you know just give me the file
name talk to him I kept asking is it
Victor okay it's Victor okay
can somebody please tell me
within an hour of contacting the US
Embassy Victor and Jaime are airlifted
to the nearest hospital yet even while
receiving treatment Victor does not feel
safe from the assassins I was terrified
to show up to the hospital I know been
an agent that the cartels kill people at
hospitals when they don't finish them
off on the field I know that I've seen
that numerous times they wanted to burn
IV on me I refused they wanted to give
me a sedative because my blood pressure
was very high then I refused the last
thing I wanted to be was impaired and
I'd be able to think straight
eventually a co-worker of mine shows up
and it was so happy to see an American
and eventually everyone showed up
FBI DEA US Marshals Secret Service
everyone show up showed up to show her
support help arrived too late for
Victor's partner that date hi Mae Zapata
who succumbed to multiple gunshot wounds
hi Mae was 32 one of five brothers in a
family with traditional links to law
enforcement he had served his country as
an ice agent for five years my older son
went into the bedroom uses mom how do
you miss did this so that was very
difficult it was just a bad nightmare
and then just reality sinks and we are
not ever gonna see my son again
and it hurts very much
the head of Homeland Security Janet
Napolitano called the ambush an attack
against all those who serve our nation
and she found to hunt down those
responsible but instead of swift justice
for the Zapatas and the analyst it was
the start of a five-year nightmare the
number one worded I think of this
we've been failed it dawned to us that
this was bigger than what we thought
this had a lot more to do with something
that I think the government was trying
to cover up On February the 15th 2011
assassins from one of Mexico's deadliest
drug cartels ambushed two US federal
agents carrying out the covert mission
Special Agent Jaime Zapata was shot and
fatally wounded his sacrifice was
recognized at the highest level it was
like the second day that Jaime passed
away that the president called and he
said on behalf of Michelle and myself
we're sorry about what happened to your
son and you know you have our
condolences
Victor Avila was also shot he too was
initially treated as a hero but within a
year that was all to change throughout
his distinguished career as a special
agent Victor
Avila had showed nothing but the utmost
loyalty to his government and his
country but then he decided to search
for the truth about what happened to him
and his partner on that fatal day five
years ago
[Music]
that search has taken Victor back here
to Mexico City it is the first time he
has returned since he was nearly killed
in the ambush but his determination to
uncover what happened to him has cost
Victor his health and his career Victor
and I had known each other for many
years since we worked together on a
story about a child smuggling gang then
one morning Victor wanted to talk to me
about the shooting on highway 57 and his
subsequent treatment by the US
government over the past five years my
duty as a special agent to them did not
matter my service I personal service to
them did not matter and that to me is a
betrayal and he started by telling me
about the route he had with his bosses
at the u.s. embassy
prior to his mission I said why are we
picking up this equipment by my Highway
Island when it could be easily sent the
diplomatic pouch and I was told that all
of that was already explored and
supervisors decided apparent it was
gonna be picked up by me and Hyman and
it now turns out that Victor had every
reason to be concerned about his safety
we've obtained this internal security
memo dated January 18 2011 and it's from
the State Department and it mentions
paste-like Monterrey and it says do not
travel through these prohibited areas
it's not worth the risk were you aware
of this memo absolutely we all received
that every US employee at the US Embassy
and we received that memo via email two
weeks after the State Department say
don't drive on that road don't go to
Monterrey it's not worth the risk you're
being sent there absolutely the this
knowledge was completely ignored by my
office I challenged it so much that I
asked my supervisor
- approached the deputy attache and the
deputy attache in so many words said he
wasn't aware of any security incidents
and India that equipment by close of
business day on Tuesday immediately
after the shooting a joint task force of
US and Mexican law enforcement headed by
the FBI was set up to trace the killers
within days they've made a number of
arrests the leader of the cartel hit
squad was identified as Julian is a
Ponte Espinosa a los zetas foot soldier
and there was another highly significant
breakthrough the weapon that was used to
murder Jaime Zapata was identified as a
Romanian manufactured ak-47 the
detective work in tracing the weapon was
carried out by the Federal Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms or ATF they
were able to trace the ak-47 back to
where it was sold the date it was
purchased and the name of the individual
who bought it
Lancaster is a small suburban community
situated 15 miles from downtown Dallas
it is the home of 27 year old Attilio
asorio known as jr. the tattoo artist
the self-confessed gun obsessive he went
to school here and then after school he
had a number of the string of odd jobs
that he worked out and he had an older
brother named bran fairy who had been in
the military I think oh those Otilio had
always had a fascination with firearms
and I think his ran fair he approached
him about helping him acquire firearms
and that's how it started a former US
Marine with tours of duty in Afghanistan
and Iraq ran ferry asorio was also
arrested and subsequently imprisoned
following the Contras
the murder weapon was bought from a
store at a gun fair run by off-duty
armory also in the Dallas suburbs
Attilio asorio told police officers it
was meant to be his lucky gun its
purchase cost him a seven-year prison
sentence
[Music]
hi Victor a long time in the five years
since the shooting Victor Claudia and
izapata family have grown close united
in their grief as they decided to launch
a joint legal action against the US
government for ordering the 2 men to
travel on highway 57 but the moment that
they started to demand answers about the
circumstances surrounding the shooting
everything changed
there were very nice they would come
over and the same thing oh yeah we're
investigated we're still trying to get
to the bottom of this was right you see
and recognize how clearly the gross
negligence was there so I have the right
to do that
I was the outcast I was a prior
it's hard to swallow just how unjustly
Victor has been treated and just to see
that's about that's who you know they
lost her son I can't even imagine what
they're going through day after day
after day not getting the answers that
they so deserve both families began to
suspect that the government's refusal to
engage with them over the shooting might
extend beyond their claim for criminal
negligence two months prior to the
attack on highway 57 in December 2010
another US federal agent Brian Terry had
been shot dead by criminals near the
Mexican border Brian Terry was a former
United States Marine who was got hired
by the United States border patrol and
worked along the southwest border in
Peck Canyon in December of 2010 he was
murdered
by what we call rip crew and a rip crew
is a group of illegal immigrants that
come across the border with the
expressed intent to rob other groups of
migrants the investigation into Terry's
murder linked the weapon to a
far-reaching operation called fast and
furious that involved the transfer of
thousands of firearms across the u.s.
Mexican border
but there was a problem
fast and furious was not a gun
trafficking conspiracy operated by the
Mexican drug cartels it was in fact
being run by the US Bureau of Alcohol
Tobacco and Firearms and it was out of
control we armed with very people that
killed Ryan Terry
[Music]
Special Agent John Dodson is a ten-year
veteran of the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco
and Firearms at one time attached to an
elite unit we were firearms trafficking
group we were investigate and prosecute
illegal firearms traffickers
specifically those trafficking to the
southwest border and ultimately these
firearms that were being trafficked the
ones that we were supposed to
investigating and stop we're ending up
in the hands of the cartels in Mexico
[Music]
Dotson is also one of America's bravest
whistleblowers the man who exposed
Operation Fast and Furious the country's
biggest law enforcement scandal for
Generation
John Dodson worked at the ATF's Phoenix
Arizona field office for a team called
Strikeforce seven also known as the
Phoenix group the Strikeforce came up
with a strategy of actively encouraging
legitimate firearms dealers to take part
in illegal sales it was known as gun
walking intended to keep the criminal
purchasers under surveillance so they
could map out their network the idea was
to track the weapons from the u.s. into
the hands of Mexico's drug cartels the
cartel members would then be prosecuted
for gun possession and for any crimes
associated with their use but in
December 2010 US border agent Brian
Terry was murdered by a weapon linked to
Fast & Furious and the ATF's response
was to try and wipe their fingerprints
they immediately cut the ties severed
the links changed the reporting in our
reporting system denied me and other
people access to the reporting system so
that we could make a connection form
they were they were doing everything
they could to cover up the fact that
Brian Terry was killed with weapons from
the Fast and Furious investigation and
what could that prompt you to do I made
the decision that I felt someone had to
know so I was contacted by congressional
investigators and they said they were
looking into it and wanted to know the
truth so I told him on television
John Dodson's revelations about fast and
furious led to an 18-month congressional
inquiry but repeated attempts to get the
whole truth about this or the existence
of other gun-walking operations proved
fruitless
the pages go on like this forever
you've given us black paper instead of
white paper you might as well have given
us a ream still in its original binder
how dare you make an opening statement
how dare you make an opening statement
of cooperation one of the many reports
that followed the investigation labeled
fast and furious a failed operation it
criticized the policy of gun walking to
the Mexican drug cartels as marred by
missteps poor judgments and called it an
inherently reckless strategy despite the
damning conclusions there is a sense
here in Congress that the full extent of
the gun-walking scandal has yet to be
revealed in all of your years have you
ever known such a refusal to pass on the
information that should be in the public
domain not where so obvious that there
was a violation of federal law I
wouldn't want to say that there aren't
other departments every department
stonewalls to some extent but I'm
tenacious I'm going to go after it I
think I have that reputation it's taken
more time because we've had more
stonewalling on fast and furious and
gun-running than any other investigation
I've done and that's over a 35-year
period of time
Victor Avila is also certain that there
is more to come out he is convinced that
his case where weapons were transferred
from the u.s. to a Mexican cartel must
in some way be linked to the wider
scandal we have requested numerous times
through many avenues not just a Freedom
of Information Act for documents
surrounding the attack and to this day
have not received one single document
from the US government it's being
covered up absolutely is a cover-up
[Music]
if there is a cover-up then I reckon the
best place to start is back in Texas it
was a matter of public record that the
ATF had traced the gun that had murdered
Jaime Zapata to a man who lived here in
Lancaster following his arrest Attilio
asorio pleaded guilty to firearms
charges and that meant his defense and
any other evidence has never been heard
in court so the next stop was at illios
lawyer to see if he could shed any light
on the case so at your request I
retrieved from archives my file on ot
Leo's case this file like any criminal
file contains all the pleadings in the
case by the parties all the legal
memoranda all the research the witness
interviews I conducted the notes that I
made that derive from the discovery I
was provided correspondence with
witnesses correspondence with my client
just materials you would expect in any
federal case and you know can we take a
look at it now
no I think most and material in this box
is still governed by protective orders
are derived from protective orders and
my understanding of the orders of the
court or that they're to the extent
there's any materials in here that might
be governed by the protective order I'm
not permitted to disclose them to
anybody so I can't see what's in the
books no not without permission of the
court that's all at all how unusual is
it that after criminal proceedings have
been concluded that a protective order
is still in place preventing someone
like me seeing the contents of this box
in my experience it's an unusual
Bruce Anton had made it clear he was not
prepared to risk contempt of court and
criminal proceedings by discussing
matter in further
and now my only chance lay with a formal
approach to the assistant US attorney in
dance mr. Tremblay I emailed you
requesting some information from an
evidence file are you saying that there
is absolutely no chance that we can lift
the protective order on this file so
that we can see some of the information
as it related to this case so I can't go
to a judge and say can it be lifted
there in place for a reason but could I
go to a judge and ask for it to be
lifted yes I understand I understand
okay thank you so much
the very short answer there was that it
is unlikely if not impossible that we'll
ever get access to this file you just
said it was not going to happen
it seemed as though we'd reached a dead
end through the federal court the US
government had ordered that all the
outstanding evidence surrounding the
guns used in the ambush on highway 57
should remain hidden from both the
families and the public
but several weeks into our investigation
all that was to change and the
breakthrough came not in Texas but at a
different location which we've chosen
not to identify
we received material crucial to our
investigation
it included a 750 page
ATF report of investigation into both
the asorio brothers from what I was able
to piece together the report suggested
that the purchase of the murder weapon
had not been an isolated incident also
contained in the files a copy of an
undercover surveillance video the
subjects ran Faria Soria and his brother
tell you they appear to be discussing
some sort of illicit gun deal and I was
now beginning to understand why the
authorities were going to such lengths
to keep everything under wraps
we now had the 750 page ATF report but
given its length and complexity it was
going to require expert analysis and
Special Agent John Dodson agreed to help
us his reading of the file reveals that
in the months leading up to the shooting
in Mexico there was a long-running
illegal arms dealing conspiracy based in
Lancaster Texas
the ringleader was 32 year old RAM
Farias oriole who had recruited his
younger brother Attilio to buy and sell
guns the file shows that in June 2010
two cars traveling south to the Mexican
border were stopped and searched by
Oklahoma City ATF agents one of the
vehicles was carrying several automatic
and semi-automatic weapons stuffed into
military duffle bags one of these bags
also contained the US Marine Corps
identity tag clearly marked with Rand
Farris neighbor address despite the
clear link between Rosario and the drone
seizure no action was taken and the
incident was not officially locked until
nine months later a serious violation of
ATF rules that require a maximum of five
days what they were doing was illegal
activity and if anything else further in
the future happened you were gonna come
down on him with all the strength of the
United States government alright with a
big heavy mallet and there would be
stuck between a very hard place and that
heavy mallet so had you done what you
should have done you could have stopped
it if by nothing more than scaring the
hell out of them and put them on notice
but because no action was taken the
asorio brother
good buying operation was allowed to
continue
dalton's investigation reveals that
three months later the trace was carried
out on two more girls that had been
found at a crime scene
the records showed that both weapons had
been bought by ran fairness oriole in
one case just eight days before the
crime again nothing was done and one
month later the murder weapon used in
the ambush on highway 57 was purchased
what your file clearly demonstrates is
the asari o brothers blip the radar long
before they made the purchase of the
firearm on October 10th 2010 which was
ultimately used to kill Jaime Zapata and
injure Victor Vito and that I think that
report documents sufficiently that they
blip the radar of such a magnitude and
frequency that something should have
been done prior to their ever having the
opportunity to purchase those guns that
were used to kill Zapata
the trace files contain no record of any
further contact between the ATF and the
asorio brothers leading up to the time
the gun was bought but we do know that
one month after the purchase of the
murder weapon
the brothers are still involved in the
illegal gun trade this surveillance
video shows them delivering two bags of
40 guns to one of the ATF's own
confidential informants working
undercover
the investigation is into drugs and
weapons trafficking by the Zetas cartel
and although the guns are subsequently
seized near the border the asuras
aren't arrested these firearms were
purchased out of Texas so I know it's
not fast and furious because fast and
furious was a case worked out of Phoenix
however as it was explained to me
several times while I was working in
Phoenix that this manner of
investigation this strategy this way of
doing things was referred to as the
Phoenix model right and it had been
exported to the other field offices and
field divisions along the southwest
border okay it's not fast and furious
but it's probably another case just like
every single attempt by Victor Avila by
the sapota family by the US Congress and
now by us to find out the truth about
the events leading up to the shooting in
Mexico has been consistently blocked the
federal authorities say they can't
comment on ongoing criminal inquiries
but those investigations have lasted for
five years now and the most senior
elected officials in the land are now
saying enough is enough once we had the
ATF report we forwarded it to Senator
Grassley the man who has spent five
years determined to get the whole truth
about the gun-walking scandal the
significance is that it's an outrage
that that information wasn't given to
Congress when we asked for it it's an
outrage that that information wasn't
given to the family and the biggest
outrage is that that information wasn't
followed to the rest of the people that
were involved and if those people have
been arrested for violating the law
Zapata may be alive
[Music]
we think about Jaime every day and I
think where he would be at right now I
think about what I can do as a mother to
find justice for him it was a human
being he was a great person great
personality he had a great life ahead of
him and it was cut short because someone
made the wrong decision
[Music]
[Music]
sometimes when I go by there and I look
at his picture I go over there and and
and it just sometimes it hits me that I
have to have to cry because I remember
the the good times that one time it was
a happy-go-lucky person
after Washington DC I had one last visit
to Victor and Claudia to tell them what
we discovered this is the file that the
US government did not want you to see
and this is the file that they didn't
want us to see either I'm not saying
that within this file are all the
answers but what I am convinced about is
that there is new information here that
you have been until this moment denied
that we will be able to show that there
was an awareness of an illegal activity
with regards to buying and selling guns
but that I don't know why nothing was
done on June 15th a duffel bag
containing weapons was found by
especially together we went through the
750 page Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms report and their surveillance
footage and I explained how the ATF had
known for months that the asorio
brothers were selling guns returning up
at crime scenes
okay
yeah
yeah but this about the family man come
to light
my family has me yes
my kids have me add me kids and my
family it's about this still gonna
Anderson
[Music]
for Victor Avila and his family the last
five years have been hell he was
seriously wounded in the line of duty
his partner killed he was first hailed
as an American Hero then for having the
courage to stand up for the truth
shunned as a pariah even though he now
feels vindicated Victor Hatherley the
still believes that justice has yet to
be served now we know that they knew and
although they they've continued to deny
stayed we know that they knew now the
bottom line is that the government has
has to be held accountable individuals
need to be held accountable no one has
been held accountable for the death of
my men my injuries no one an agent was
killed in the line of duty in a foreign
country and no one has been held
accountable not the White House not the
Department of Justice not the Department
of Homeland Security ATF no one has been
held accountable
[Music]